l'abbiamo fatta in duemila modi
l'abbiamo celebrata nella sua essenza
più tradizionale per poi violentarla
senza vergogna rimanendo impuniti perché
siamo una società patriarcale composta
da maschi bianchi e the roaches gender
da quella francese cotta nel suo liquame
e che ancora mi perseguitano i miei
incubi peggiori a quella che ha
preparato gordon ramsay con prosciutto e
funghi piselli e unghie dei piedi della
nuvola apre la finestra lancio di sotto
di quella vegana che sapeva di saliva
lasciato al sole a quella microonde che
mi è costata mesi di terapia
ma noi siamo un programma di
autolesionista ed è per questo che
tenteremo un'ennesima versione di questo
piazza dove ci hanno messo abbastanza
non renderlo immortale poi di per se
l'accoppiata degli ingredienti che
renderà mortale
[Musica]
ciao a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a una
puntata di cucina buttata l'unico format
all'interno del quale il cibo non è un
piacere ma una grande sofferenza oggi ne
torniamo un biglietto per roma cioè noi
lo viviamo perché ci abitiamo a roma e
la bruciamo come ha fatto nerone oggi
affonderemo le mani nella tradizione
della capitale come sia fondono nella
merda dinosauro in jurassic park
e ad aiutarci sarà proprio lui il nostro
piatto la carbonara dolce per farne la
carbonara dolce avremo bisogno di 180
grammi di spaghetti 2 litri d'acqua la
scorza di mezza arancia 50 g di zucca o
30 grammi di amido di mais 300
millilitri di latte scremato quanto
basta di cui 200 grammi di fragole 6
grammi di pallini di cioccolato
oggi però non cucinerò da solo a darmi
una mano sarà una mia amica che ammiro
tantissimo una ragazza che ha
letteralmente le mani d'oro nel senso
che è nata in una matita e vi creerà dei
capolavori date nella padella molto
probabilmente dipingerà la vostra fine
ho il piacere di avere come ospite negli
studios della cucina mia francesca
presentini oppure se preferite fra frog
questa che cola cola rosa sono pronto a
fare un paio di domande allora la prima
è sei contenta innanzitutto di essere a
roma e che tra le tante cose buone che
c'è da punti netti prepariamo sul piatto
del merda ma io non ho ancora capito la
ricetta però la ricetta è una carbonara
dolce quindi con lo zucchero tu come sei
in cucina
presente cioè tipo qual è il tuo piatto
forte non ci interessa perché tanto non
lo faremo passiamo ai grembiuli
ok con vivi complimenti vai
o no
diciamo che è proprio la post produzione
che ha dei problemi
nico è rotto il cazzo ho preparato
sciroppo per la tosse familiare
prima di partire con questa ricetta
potete ringraziare il blog cubi ricette
col quale condividiamo la colpa di
quello che stiamo facendo per questa
ricetta
quindi
pentola sul fuoco aggiungi milano questo
è il livello facile cioè senza una
goccia fuori
che accendimi il fornello festeggeranno
allora difficile
non ci credo io ci ho messo sette anni e
due di induzione a casa ma la vorrei
ok questo qui va fatto riscaldare e poi
per un ora bisogna lasciarlo infusione
proseguiamo con la crema ok fra questo
qui è tua grazia avrebbe abbiamo un
setaccio serve un sito
09 gama in questa vicenda non c'entrano
non vogliamo
darci tempo comunque di industriale
nelle fasi non è questo il bello di
questo format che cosa che fa schifo
tutto ci sono dei livelli di difficoltà
dati dalla dimensione delle cose
stavo cercando di mettere in difficoltà
in tutti i modi poi ma poi se tu
avvicinarsi il setaccio
aggiungiamo lo zucchero
ormai di latte niente sei proprio una
prova
tu non sai che cosa fa quello è un
adattatore per cosa che picco il top
comunque veramente ti stai in settimana
e ha cercato in cui quel coso pacchetti
rumori strani e muovere naturale
e normale cosa fare per
toglierlo
tutto bene intanto olympics il
ragazzino e non propongo un cambio una
padella fidati su quella che ami calcola
amica fidati ok ma che cosa sta
succedendo a lavorare in questa
condizione chiamatemi mandato il
topolino allora ragazzi mentre mi porto
avanti questa crema fra andato un
secondo a fare una piccola roba di
lavoro per cui finalmente possiamo dire
adesso c'è un professionista dietro a
queste fornelli mamma mia a questo punto
ragazzi si aggiunge un pochino di
curcuma devo darle un colore un nuovo
show che vede che siete relatori citato
quello di ragya non vedere mai il cuore
dell'uomo patetico non hai fatto l'uovo
quello che ho fatto loro
l'uomo ma sii serio fammi controllare
gli effetti
effetti collaterali diventare un
imbecille non è fra questi e di odio che
106 la foto 7 ma sono latore che tu sei
nato da quattro anni tu se il paziente
zero del copit tu sei il pipistrello che
ha infettato la cina il treno dopo un
ragazzo mi raccomando ripeterà nella
quale avevamo messo le scorze d'arancia
e metterà fissate chiedetevi che cazzo
di fine ha fatto francesca è ancora qui
con noi ce la farà è stata forse rapita
da un grigino dopo che vi sarete posti
queste domande e poi avrete scrollato le
spalle 19 ragazze i suoi togliete tutte
quante le scorze d'arancia
[Musica]
un grigino però è assurdo ma dove
le presine non c'era mi sembra come
quando ti fa il canarino che
tu mi fai impazzire
oddio ma raccoglie e rideva senza dirmi
nulla serve un coppino ha contate
gianmarco questo qualcosa per il
ghiaccio per evitare del tempo per
attrezzarci nel tempo per attrezzarci in
coppino ma che non testa riuscì scusa
guarda che roba
di tutto quanto avremmo più o meno
questo
noi forniamo col grillo e aspettiamo che
faccia leggermente una crosticina sopra
non lo so perché non perché così vivono
prendiamo le fragole e le tagliamo a
cubettini come se vi fossero pezzetti di
guanciale immagini
[Musica]
è un cretino
è al momento a questo punto di
assemblare il nostro piatto
[Musica]
questa qui è la nostra carbonara dolce
prima di passare all'assaggio ragazzi
non dimenticatevi di iscrivervi a questo
canale metterci un bel pollice su anche
se in questo momento so che mi sto
chiedendo tanto perché temo di aver
fatto una cacata oggi una cacata detto
così provata commentate scrivendo
condividete questo video nelle bacheche
delle persone chiamate che odiate di
cianni perché questa ha detto ciò un
cuoricino passiamo agli assaggi
mamma mia sto provando tra stream e
ancora una delle ricette peggiori di
cucina puntata disdicevole vomitevole
abbiamo tenuto tutti quanti noi
francesca è ancora viva sì è una
confessione soltanto per voi non me ne
sono andata perché sono una snob da
fare casi notizia infatti è tornata
super dispiaciuta quindi sei tornata
proprio per per l'assaggio non era se
non hai idea di quello che sai per
assaggiare abbiamo far incrociato
[Musica]
c'è di meglio e da quando me ne sono
andata io probabilmente questo video è
solo peggiorato sì sicuramente ma ti
posso dire che adesso che si è tornata
non mi sembra che abbia cambiato sapore
problema che sembra che vuole la gente
lo ripaga mi
fate ragazzi non rifare a casa fra ha
detto ciò mentre tu torni ad assaporare
il tuo piatto io ti ringrazio per questo
video insieme se vuoi un giorno invece
io verrò nel tuo canale è bello e ti
farò vedere come ti sei io ti prego
perché tutti i segni anche molto bene
sono qui prova di segnare che ha
cucinato e che ci vuole poco secondo me
sono anche più bravo costruire case da
cucinare detto ciò grazie mille per per
essere venuta a ospitare dell'invito e
soprattutto ragazzi grazie a voi ciao
ciao
[Musica]
[Applauso]